>> Harris: IAN IS ON THE MOVE IN
STATES LIKE GEORGIA AND THE
CAROLINAS HAVE DECLARED STATES
OF EMERGENCY AHEAD OF THE STORM.
WHILE THE GOVERNORS ARE
PREPARING FOR THE STORM, IT
SEEMS THE LEFT IS PLAYING
POLITICS WITH IT AND USING THE
DISASTER AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PUSH THEIR CLIMATE AGENDA.
>> YOU KNOW MORE ARE COMING,
WE'LL BE DEALING WITH THIS AS A
NATION GOING INTO THE FUTURE, IF
WE CAN'T GET CLIMATE UNDER
CONTROL.
>> THIS IS WHAT CLIMATE
SCIENTISTS HAVE BEEN WARNING
ABOUT AND WE ARE SEEING IT
UPCLOSE.
>> WHAT EFFECT IS CLIMATE CHANGE
HAVING ON THIS PHENOMENA, THE
STORMS ARE --
>> I DON'T THINK YOU CAN LINK
CLOO CLIMATE --
>> SOMETHING IS CAUSING THEM TO
INTENSIFY.
>> I SAW THE DON LEMON MOMENT
AND HE JUST GOT LECTURED BY
ROYAL EXPERT ON HISTORY AND
DIDN'T TURN OUT WELL.
THE EXPERTS SAID TO HIM, WE
CAN'T LINK A SPECIFIC STORM TO
THAT, BUT YET DON LEMON DOUBLES
BACK TRYING TO PUSH HIS IDEOLOGY
ON THE EXPERT AND TRIES TO END
IT ALL BY SAYING I GREW UP
THERE, IT IS JUST AMAZING AND
THIS IS BEFORE THE STORM HIT.
IT IS NOT A MOMENT FOR POLITICS
OR AGENDA.
>> GOOD ON THE DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL HURRICANE CENTER, WE
WANT TO HAVE A DISCUSSION, WE
CAN AT SOME POINT AND WE WILL
PROBABLY DISAGREE ISSUE BUT NOT
NOW.
THEY CAN'T RESIST THE MOMENT, IT
IS PRESENT-ISM OR MOMENT-ISM,
THIS HAS TO BE THE WORST MOMENT,
INTENSIFYING AND HAS TO BE
CLIMATE CHANGE.
THE PROBLEM IS, IT IS ALWAYS THE
DEFAULT, BUT IT IS NOT ALWAYS
RIGHT EMPLOYEES HOTTER, COLDER,
WETTER, DRYER, IT IS NOT AS BAD,
IT IS CLIMATE CHANGE, YOU ARE
MAKING A RELIGIOUS ARGUMENT.
>> SENATOR KLOBUCHAR TALKED
ABOUT THE INFLATION REDUCTION
ACT, SHE HAD TO THIS SAY.
>> WE JUST DID SOMETHING ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE FOR FIRST TIME IN
DECADES, WE HAVE TO WIN THIS AS
THAT HURRICANE BEARS DOWN ON
FLORIDA, WIN IN THE MIDTERM.
>> HARRIS, THAT WAS A MOMENT.
>> Harris: I'VE INTERVIEWED HER
MANY TIMES, AMY KLOBUCHAR, SHE'S
VERY BRIGHT, WHEN YOU GET CAUGHT
UP IN THE MOMENT OVER POLITICS
AND THE MOST COPIOUS THING IS TO
SAY STOP HURRICANES WITH
LEGISLATION, YOU COULDN'T STOP
INFLATION WITH SOMETHING CALLED
INFLATION REDUCTION ACT, FORGIVE
THE WORLD IF WE DON'T BELIEVE
WHAT IS COMING OUT OF YOUR MOUTH
ANYMORE.
IT IS UNFORTUNATE, SOME
POLITICIANS HAVE GOOD IDEAS, I
DON'T KNOW IF ANY OF THEM CAN
STOP A HURRICANE.
>> Kayleigh: THAT IS RIGHT, IT
IS LIKE THE PARIS CLIMATE
ACCORD, WE WITHDRAW AND
HURRICANES BEGAN ISSUE THE
LARGEST HURRICANE WAS IN 1935.
>> TO MAKE REFERENCE, I'VE LIVED
IN FLORIDA AND IT IS GETTING
WORSE, UNLESS HE IS 100 YEARS
OLD, MORE HURRICANES HITTING
FLORIDA THAN PRESENT DAY, YOU
WOULD HAVE THOUGHT IT WAS
ARMAGEDDON, WE DID NOT LIVE ON
THE COASTLINE, IT HAS TO DO WITH
PERSPECTIVE.
LOOK AT THE STORMS THAT HAPPENED
AND WHAT IS OCCURRING, THAT IS
IMPORTANT WHEN YOU WANT TO USE
INFORMATION AROUND ENVIRONMENTAL
CHANGE, NUMBER IN SCIENCE AND
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN THE LAND
THEY ARE HAPPENING ON AND THE
OTHER BIG THING, YES, THE CHANGE
IS OCCURRING, THE OCEAN WAS 88
TO 90 DEGREES WE SEE WARMER SEA
SURFACE TEMPERATURES, THAT CAN
APPLY TO A STORM THAT IS BAD AND
MAKE IT WORSE, A DIFFERENT
ARGUMENT TO HAVE.
DAGEN.
>> Dagen: THESE TALKING HEADS GO
ON AND REPEAT WHAT THEY HEAR AT
A CONGRESSIONAL HEARING ON
CLIMATE MISINFORMATION.
MICHAEL SHELLENBERGER SAYS
EXPERTS CLAIMED HURRICANES ARE
BECOMING MORE FREQUENT AND NEW
YORK IS MOVING AWAY FROM
NATIONAL GAS, NEW YORK IS
INCREASING USE OF NATURAL GAS
AND OIL AND SCIENTISTS AT
NATIONAL OCEAN GRAPHIC AND
AERONAUTIC ADMINISTRATION
PREDICTED 25% DECREASE IN
ATLANTIC HURRICANE A